[музика]
мені постійно чулося коли я на вулиці
ходив що мама мене гукала Я оборачувався
думаю може вона прийшла по мене у
розмові з 13тирічним Сашком найчастіше
звучить єдине слово мама саме
відсутність матері поруч ось уже майже
два роки змусила хлопця вже не відчувати
себе дитиною як він каже сам після
примусової депортації і фактично полону
у так званій ДНР він змушений шукати
Влас маму з якою після оточення
Маріуполя розлучили російські окупанти я
з нею не бачився з 15
квітня 22го року Вона потрапила в
полон за стільки
часу Я нічого про неї не
чув регулярно хлопець переглядає останні
світлини З мамою які збереглися в
соцмережах на них Сніжана Козлова разом
з чоловіком і двома дітьми Стар ши сином
Олександром та донькою Вікторією
зустрічає родинні свята і гуляє
Маріуполем саме там родина застала
повномасштабне вторгнення Росії в
Україну відчим хлопця пішов на фронт а
мама з ним і сестрою мала виїхати до
бабусі на чернігівщину вона мені
подзвонила 24 лютого Мамо що мені робити
А я кажу куди люди туди ти А що робить а
людей вивозять і я не знаю де вони
сиділи Я думала мо їх вивозять де виїжа
Ну то що не получилось так ми думали
пересидіть і тоді
виїхати вже було чутно і
вибухи ну і там ми перебували в нас було
мало їжі Ну ми економить старалися Ну ми
в подвалі в підвалі нашого будинку
ховалися все змінилось 24 березня тоді
був обстріл сильний я в той момент був
на подвір'ї біля мангала
я й побіг боявся За сестричку побіг туди
на другий поверх і тільки я забігаю в
під'їзд добігаю на другий поверх і тут
вибух а там снаряд ви пря Міна на мій
будинок випала
впала якось воно мені вгла щось начало
пекти дуже уламок від снаряда серйозно
уразив око хлопця єдиними лікарями які
залишалися у місті були військові медики
до них не взявши документів і лишивши
меншу дитину у батьківчи ока Сніжана
повезла сина в укриття в заводі імені
ліча на той час там перебували сотні
українських захисників зокрема
підрозділи 36ї окремої бригади морської
піхоти ЗСУ ну це був бункер там був
військовий
шпиталь ну і там постійно обстрілювали і
світло пропадало я хотів мультики
скачать останню гру свою видалив і не
хватило пам'яті була капець Не було
інтернета я там познайомимся з одним
дядьком його звать Гена позивний Хан я
йому допомагав там у всьом лікувати його
12 квітня 2022 року завод був повністю
оточений російськими солдатами з усіма
українськими захисниками здатися в полон
реф довелося і Саші та його мамі у
фільтраційному таборі у селі безіменне
поблизу Маріуполя Сніжану допитували по
кілька годин а по її сина того ж дня
приїхала пара невідомих вони не дали
йому попрощатися з мамою і забрали в
Донецьку лікарню на лікування втім
жодної допомоги хлопцю не надали
натомість пізніше пообіцяли відправити
до дидбудинку в Росії Я думав що це На
шуті що щчас нас разом заберуть кудась Я
думав що її повернуть дуже бистро мені
було дуже страшно без мами смисл їм В
чом їм Вигода Вигода даже якби там
зробили операцію в Донецьку то я би міг
ще щось бачити А зараз як А сечас уже ну
дуже погано бачу цим глазом а кудись в
якийсь там Лагер хотіли повести я
отказувався я думав Лучше я буду сидіть
дома ну там в
лікарні ждатиму
бабуш Одного дня хлопцеві вдалося вийти
на зв'язок з бабусею хоч йому і не
дозволяли дзвонити телефон дала одна з
місцевих пацієнток лікарні душа чує що
десь мене шукається в дійсності Мені
Саша дзвонить каже баб без тебе не не
заберуть ніхто треба тільки тобі їхать а
мати мати кажу де каже не знаю Я кажу
Давай мені соціальну службу яка там
должна до тебе підійти давай мені
врачиху Давай мені адрес Де ти находишся
І все я листок і ручка і пишу жінка
вирушила до окупованого Донецька поонука
написати чи Подзвонити бабусі ще раз
хлопцеві не дозволили врешті через
балтійсь країни та території Росії
Людмила змогла дістатися так званої ДНР
там у травні
2022го відбулася її зустріч з хлопчиком
одразу після цього вони вирушили додому
назад через Росію по приїзду на
чернігівщину жінка з онуком взялися
разом шукати маму хлопчика спершу фото
Сніжани публікували у онлайн групах
родичів зниклих безвісти українців потім
писали десятки листів у міжнародне
інформаційне бюро та до президента
України з проханням допомогти з пошуком
минулого року Олександр Радчук їздив до
Швейцарського давоса на міжнародний
економічний форум де просив Польського
Президента анджея Дуду та британського
прем'єр-міністра Бориса Джонсона
вплинути на міжнародну спільноту аби
почати розшук мами в Росії в конці
лютого я ще поїду в Америку моя основна
мета
довести країнам іншим що Росія агресор
що вони мені допомогли мою маму
Звільнити з Поло Ну я думаю вона десь є
вона десь
дитино моя як мені нам тебе не хватає
знайдися відгукнися хоч відгуктися де ти
ну чекаємо все-таки
чекаємо Сашко і його бабуся роблять
чергову спробу дізнатися де мама вони
їдуть до Києва на зустріч із керівником
волонтерських груп пошуку зниклих
українців Олегом котенком торік
уповноваженим з питань зниклих безвісти
осіб Олег Котенко припускає що найбільш
вірогідне місцеперебування Сніжани
козлової - це тюрма для
військовополонених у таганрозі куди
відвезли інших встановлених полонених з
Маріуполя то що малого повернули ну це
уже щастя її рахують військовою але рано
чи пізно вони розберуться я знаю це 501й
батальйон 36-ї бригади вони були на
іліча вони дійсно з пораненими Я не знав
що там таке відбулося я від це вперше
почув про те що там були щей цивільні
Україна веде перемовини чи через ме
міжнародні організації але на цьому
потрібно акцентувати увагу щоб офіційно
подати запит на інформацію про маму
Сашка у Червоний Хрест Аті в Росію
волонтери допомагають хлопчику і його
бабусі правильно оформити документи на
розшук за цими даними можуть піти тижні
і місяці за той час хлопець готується
далі боротися за власний зір після
поранення і зробити операцію на оці у
Київській лікарні я хочу стати
пожежником ось закінчу школу потім поїду
вчитися щоб допомагати другим людям що
коли якщо вони будуть в біді щоб їм
допомагати хлопець зізнається ДВ дає
інтерв'ю з думкою про те що є хоча б
найменший шанс що в мережі це відео
побачить його
мама